I feel like some girls like Demi and
Hanabi look I'm Heather they're not as
ready for marriage and if that's what he
wants then great but I want to be very
clear in order for him to find his wife
he's got to make a lot of changes and
hopefully he can hear me and understand
what I'm actually saying to him if not
then I I gotta go I think I can get more
out of this from you and from us but I
don't want it I don't know I want I want
that too yeah and I feel like ever since
someone's like hey hear that you're the
bachelor a lot of everybody expects me
to have everything figured out and it's
like I don't have it figured out I'm not
naive to the fact that there's other
people are in I know every relationship
is so different my fear that also is
with the choices that you've been making
you are taking a lot of easier choices
with the people that you are pursuing I
want something like real and I want
something magical and I want everything
that you're looking for there's some
very wonderful people in that group
figure out what you came here to fight
don't be distracted by shiny things
especially now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]